[Musique]
comment es-tu devenu écrivain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien j'ai quitté la maison à 15 ans je suis allé voir
et quand j'avais 18 ans on m'a fait descendre d'un bateau
en Allemagne et on m'a dit que je ne pouvais pas
vivre plus de deux  mois,
j'ai passé trois ans et demi
à l'hôpital, j'ai fini par couper
10 côtes
sans laisser beaucoup de moi
en fait
et pendant ce temps, j'ai commencé à lire
et ils ont eu trois occasions différentes
j'étais censé  mourir et je savais que deux
choses allaient m'arriver juste
avant de mourir numéro un
je regretterais toute ma vie et numéro
deux je voudrais revivre ma vie
et ensuite je mourrais et cela m'a terrifié à
l'idée de  vivre cependant de nombreuses années
80 90 ans quoi qu'il en soit
et regarder ma vie à la fin de
cette période et réaliser que je n'ai
absolument rien fait de ma vie
m'a terrifié alors j'ai attrapé une machine à écrire
et
après deux semaines j'ai écrit une lettre combien de
temps a fait  ça t'a pris d'écrire la
dernière sortie à brooklyn six ans j'ai  j'avais un
travail je
soutenais une famille et je rentrais à la maison le
soir et je passais quelques heures à
écrire tous les soirs et j'y ai travaillé
pendant six ans vous n'êtes jamais allé à l'école
et vous n'avez jamais lu
comment avez-vous réussi à obtenir un tel  un
style sophistiqué
bien parce que je pense à quelque chose qui
m'est arrivé j'ai compris
que la responsabilité première de l'
artiste
est d'être libre de l'ego humain que je
n'ai pas le droit de m'imposer
entre l'oeuvre et le lecteur alors je l'ai fait
tout ce que j'ai travaillé très dur pour me
sortir du livre et j'écris à l'
oreille
donc la musique est très importante pour moi
donc je dois développer un style d'écriture
une typographie
qui reflète ce que j'entends et je dois
trouver les
mots exacts  décrire ce que je vois et ce que je
ressens et ce que je veux faire, c'est faire
vivre au lecteur une expérience émotionnelle,
ce qui signifie que je dois ressentir
chaque émotion
que je mets dans le livre par qui avez-
vous été influencé par l'écriture que
je fais  Je ne sais pas si j'ai été influencé b  y
celine mais je me sens
plus proche de lui à bien des égards que tout
autre écrivain
nous avons tous été influencés par james joyce
mais ma principale
influence consciente en tant qu'écrivain est
beethoven comment expliquez-vous que les
romans suivants ont eu moins de
succès je n'ai pas ii  Je ne sais pas quelle est
la seule explication à laquelle je peux penser au
moins aux États-Unis,
c'est qu'avec les derniers œufs, la plupart des gens
pourraient mépriser
les gens de la dernière sortie et ne pas voir
qu'ils sont les mêmes qu'eux mais avec
le  d'autres livres
il y avait trop de menace parce
que c'est juste n'importe qui qui marche dans la rue
et c'est trop une menace pour eux
je pense que c'est
peut-être la principale raison pour laquelle vous avez vendu deux
millions d'
exemplaires et ensuite vous avez été obligé de vivre
de l'aide
sociale j'étais  sur l'aide sociale il y a environ quatre ans, donc
vous savez que c'est comme près de 20 ans
après la
publication du livre et j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps à
rester en vie et j'ai eu des problèmes physiques
et je me suis aussi fait plaisir pendant quelques
années et j'ai
réussi à jeter un  beaucoup d'argent
mais tout s'assemble à la fin
pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas venu vivre en europe
maintenant il y a une bonne question
pourquoi n'est-ce pas j'étais probablement trop ivre pour
monter dans un avion je ne sais pas
il semble  pour moi, j'aurais dû faire ça
euh je ne sais pas tu sais parfois tu
chantes tu ne peux tout simplement pas sortir par la
porte d'entrée
hé tu as peur vous les punks peut-être que
vous êtes venu ici mais vous êtes sûr que
[ __ ] vous n'obtiendrez pas  Dehors,
aucun camion ne sortira d'ici,
tu m'entends.
oh
vous savez pourquoi kubrick le palmer
et arthur hiller l'ont fait et robert de niro
n'ont pas réussi
à faire ce film je vais vous dire ce que
je crois
je ne crois pas que le film est un
film de destin et
et il devait être  exactement au bon moment
avec
exactement les bonnes personnes et brûlé
archiga
et yuli edel sont exactement les bonnes
personnes
et c'est exactement le bon moment je
pense que c'est pour ça que ça n'a pas été fait
avant le scénario
est moins sombre que le livre es-tu d'accord
avec ça
quand le film est fini et que tu quittes
la salle c'est pareil que quand tu
finis  le livre
le livre est implacable il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de lumière
pas d'espoir dans le livre cependant ce qui arrive
au lecteur et c'est ce que beaucoup de
gens m'ont dit,
c'est que le livre est si horrible
qu'ils
finissent par avoir un sentiment de compassion pour
ceux-ci  les gens
donc bien que le livre soit si sombre
qu'ils finissent par se rendre compte qu'ils sont
capables d'aimer quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'
amour,
il y a donc un résultat très positif
pour le lecteur
et pour que cela apparaisse à l'écran, des
changements ont dû être
apportés et  c'est le résultat final du
film
bien qu'il y ait beaucoup de violence et de
brutalité
à l'écran le résultat final est que vous
ne le faites pas quand vous sortez du théâtre
vous ne voulez blesser personne mais
vous aimeriez le faire  quelque chose
pour quelqu'un donc  le résultat final à l'intérieur
est le même que dans le livre et le film
parlez-moi du personnage que vous jouez dans
le film
georgie était responsable de mon écriture
du livre en premier lieu
j'avais écrit une partie de la reine est morte
et j'ai découvert que georgie  avait été
retrouvé mort dans la rue
et cela m'a beaucoup ému et j'ai fini d'
écrire l'histoire parce que je sentais
que georgie ne devrait tout simplement pas être un
cadavre oublié
mais qu'il devrait y avoir une certaine dignité un
souvenir et donc j'ai terminé l'histoire
et de là est venu  le livre donc il semblait
approprié et poétique
que je conduise la voiture qui tue
georgie et nous pouvons enfin
mettre georgie au repos et le laisser trouver un
peu de paix où
et comment vivez-vous maintenant je vis à los
angeles et en
fait à west hollywood et je vis
confortablement maintenant car je n'ai pas eu
de travail au cours des deux dernières années,
j'ai assez d'argent provenant du
film
pour me permettre de rester à la maison et d'écrire
et je suis plutôt un heureux très paisible
votre haine pour l'humanité
et partir  Je disparais avec l'âge,
il y a une citation d'un vieux
philosophe espagnol qui dit que
ceux qui nient Dieu le nient à cause
du désespoir de ne pas le trouver
et à cause de ce qui s'est passé dans ma
vie, j'ai découvert quelque chose en moi,
je suppose que certaines personnes l'appellent  dieu je
n'aime pas trop utiliser ce mot parce que
c'est un mot difficile que les
gens comprennent mal et ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai découvert n'a rien à
voir avec l'église
ou la religion il n'y a rien dans le
concept de dieu de personne mais
un pouvoir infini et inconditionnel
l'amour qui a créé et maintient l'
univers
s'est révélé à moi de l'intérieur
ici
et j'essaie de vivre selon les
principes que ce pouvoir
établit beaucoup de gens pensent que vous
méritez un prix nobel
entendez-vous ici pourquoi pas
je vais  même payer le ticket
youtube méthamphétamine